question can you build muscle like a
bodybuilder using only calisthenics
[Music]
answer yes you can
actually
when you think of bodybuilding you tend
to think of cable machines dumbbells and
barbells you tend to think of exercises
designed to isolate specific muscle
groups bodybuilders likewise tend to use
fairly heavy weight in order to get to
that point faster bodybuilders don't
lift as much as power lifters or strong
men but they still need a certain amount
of stimulus this simply isn't possible
with body weight right that's why you
can't build a bodybuilder like physique
from your bedroom you need the gym
only
do you
[Music]
first up bodybuilding is what you want
it to be
some people take issue with the term
functional training because they think
it's nebulous all training is functional
they argue therefore no training is
functional thereby the whole concept is
a scam
well what about bodybuilding all
training builds your body right and yet
nobody calls bodybuilding not a thing
anyway my point is that bodybuilding can
be whatever you want it to be you don't
have to Aspire to be Ronnie Coleman it's
true you won't get to that point with
body weight training but to my eye Frank
Zane has a far more pleasing physique
likewise I generally prefer the look of
natural bodybuilders and this is a bit
more achievable and you'd be surprised
just how much size and definition you
can pack on with body weight training
alone
now you might think that training with
your body weight fails to provide enough
resistance or isolation to truly build
muscle this is not the case firstly it's
very simple to increase the difficulty
of a body weight exercise this is
accomplished by moving to a more complex
progression that will either remove one
limb from the equation or place it more
of a mechanical disadvantage usually by
lengthening the lever arm this basically
means moving a point of contact with the
ground further from the center of
gravity
sometimes you will Elevate part of your
body to increase the effect of gravity
say for example you can make a push-up
more difficult increasing the resistance
by performing them one-handed by placing
your legs on a raised platform or by
moving your arms out in front of you or
by moving your arms further down your
body how about performing handstand
push-ups in some cases this can be used
to build more muscle the issue however
is the lack of isolation you guys know
that on this channel I'm interested in
building the mind as well as building
the body and that's where today's
sponsor comes in skillshare so
essentially this is crowdsourced
learning members of the community can
create their own classes and then
viewers such as ourselves can watch them
at our Leisure I was actually a member
of skillshare long before I started
working with them I used skillshare to
learn programming skills to improve my
video editing my presentation skills
really it's been a big part in allowing
me to do this as a career and of course
this being the start of New Year is the
perfect time to be thinking about career
skillshare not only provides you with
all the skills you might need for a
career change but it also has a lot of
career Focus classes a great exam sample
is build a creative career full-time or
freelance which is curated by skillshare
themselves lately I've been watching
Adobe Illustrator CC Essentials training
by Daniel Scott and that's something
that I'm really interested in getting
better at I highly recommend skillshare
and the first 1000 people to sign up
down below using the link in the
description you'll also get one month
free so they can try it out at no risk
to them thanks so much once again to
skillshare for sponsoring this video and
now on with the show
so the problem with using the one-handed
push-up example to build your pecs for
instance is that this is a technical
movement that also requires a lot of
muscles working together you don't fail
to do one-arm push-ups because one Peck
has reached the point of fatigue usually
rather you fail to do one-arm push-ups
because the Collective Strength of
several muscle groups including a lot of
core muscles is no longer great enough
likewise you're more likely to reach
failure performing handstand push-ups
because you can no longer balance
yourself not because your shoulders have
reached failure
and this lack of isolation also reduces
the fine control you otherwise have over
which muscles you want to sculpt and
hone
luckily there are a few things we can do
about this
first we select calisthenics exercises
that do more or less focus on a single
muscle or at least a few together so for
example the pull-up is a compound
pulling exercise but it's pretty darn
good at focusing on the lats likewise
the chin up is pretty great for
targeting the biceps
remember you don't need to totally
isolate the muscle it's fine if a few
supporting muscles chip in most
bodybuilding movements aren't completely
isolated unless it's a single joint
Movement Like A bicep curl say and even
then there are caveats other great
examples include tricep dips for the
triceps and one-armed tricep dips if you
need something harder the same goes for
one arm chin-ups dips are fantastic for
the chest although they also work the
triceps and shoulders a lot planche
training is surprisingly good for
building big biceps and you can tweak a
lot of more common exercises in order to
change the area of focus so for example
Hindu squats vs air squats move the
pressure from the glutes and hamstrings
and more so to the quads [ __ ] squats
take this to the next level and can
build some pretty impressive legs
diamond push-ups hit the triceps more so
than regular push-ups decline push-ups
will Target the upper chest more Pike
push-ups really Target the shoulders
one of the key factors there when it
comes to building muscle with
calisthenics is to maintain the time
under tension and the continuous time
under tension this is what will allow
for a metabolic buildup which is one of
the most useful triggers for hypertrophy
basically what we're talking about here
is not resting with your arms fully
locked out or fully extended
you've seen me do lots of fast push-ups
with an almost partial range of motion
this accomplishes that and this is one
way in which you can get that growth
from very High Reps rather than just
very high weight we've all seen prisoner
workouts that consist of hundreds of air
squats and push-ups it's how Tyson built
insane legs with squats very high rep
training does build muscle just select
movements that are closed to chain or
otherwise very safe to perform in high
doses you can also accomplish this in
almost the opposite way with a really
good controlled range of motion this
once again keeps the muscle under
tension while at the same time building
strong attendance and greater control
there are more techniques you can use as
well I like to use mechanical drop sets
or the variation I call Gauntlet sets
that means I'll take the most
challenging version of the movement and
then switch to the easier version with
minimal rest
generally I keep rest Times short when
focusing on either bodybuilding or
strength endurance which tend to go hand
in hand
another option is to use pre-exhaust
sets if the chest isn't what's giving up
first during your dips then get it there
faster by doing a few push-ups first
getting a very good stretch on the
muscle is also very effective for muscle
building and it also strengthens tendons
and is useful in lots of other ways
and my guess is that the hypertrophy
benefits here come from causing more
muscle damage
or you can provide yourself with more
support or even use cheat reps by making
the exercise easier you allow yourself
to do more repetitions focusing on the
specific muscle group
now for those of you who are about to
comment there's no way he built his
physique with just body weight training
which is a comment I get on a lot of my
videos you're probably new here I very
much do mix up different training
modalities and I'm a huge advocate for
that it's kind of my thing all I'm
saying is that you can build a lot of
muscle and definition using just body
weight you'd be surprised at just how
much of my muscle comes directly from
bodyweight training about eighty percent
of my pecs probably because that's how
that works right
in fact predominantly calisthenics
athletes like Simon Arthur Daniel
radnell from Fitness faq's Austin Dunham
and gabo satano have incredible
physiques those guys got there by being
absolutely world class in their field
and their physiques are byproducts of
that performance rather than being
actively sculpted as a bodybuilder might
but you can get there faster and without
necessarily being able to do some of the
things they can do by focusing more on
hypertrophy as your main objective
using the strategies I just shared this
might mean you achieve those high level
skills a little slower than if you
prioritize skill training especially if
you're adding more weight on but it's
all a matter of knowing your own goals
and adjusting your programs to match and
as always I kind of want both
it's also about training in a very
mindful manner so that you really feel
the right muscles doing the work if
that's your goal or so that you maximize
your recovery and focus on practicing
skills if that's your goal and of course
for the best results I highly recommend
mixing your calisthenics with other
modalities body weight plus weight
lifting is fantastic for bodybuilding
skill development strength functional
performance and pretty much anything
else just make sure to put the complex
skill based movements at the start of
the workout along with any heavy
compound lifts and you'll be golden
so what do you guys think can you build
a bodybuilder like physique using just
body weight training do you guys use
body weight training or do you prefer
weights let me know in the comments down
below if you're looking for a training
program that combines body weight
training with weights and also a whole
bunch of other modalities whether you're
talking about kettlebells Mobility
training all kinds of other stuff then
you might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
that comes with over two hours of
instructional video as well as an 80
plus page ebook and there's a big
discount on right now for the January
sales I'll put a link to that in the
description down below
either way guys thank you so much for
watching this one and I'll see you next
time
bye for now